you're gonna have a good time tonight
[Music]
okay
[Music]
two
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you're never gonna finish
[Music]
this your is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to moses and friends i
am your host moses storm
this is the show where we take all of
our favorite people from the team coco
world and we put them up live whether
it's actors comedians musicians
entertainment lawyers you name it uh the
show
is um well let's say this it's not gonna
be
the best thing of your day it might be
something great we hope to distract you
for a little bit on this very weird year
that you are having it's just happening
to you personally no one else we're all
killing it
the most we could say is that maybe we
could bum you out
so much that you would feel better about
your life and isn't that something
to walk away with you know what at least
i didn't choose to be a sad
touring clown for a profession i have
job security
my three guests tonight we're gonna do
something a little different bring them
on all at once
uh alex edelman who has an album out
called until
now very funny comedian jack knight who
you know from big mouth
and a comedian that means the most to me
has been a huge influence
on my career she's got an audible
special out countless specials on
netflix
maria bamford so welcome everyone to the
show
jack maria and alex
oh my god alex do you have a room that's
less
echoey but we loved your cnn background
the audio is a little like right jewish
specialist
oh that's worse now go back go back to
your cnn room that's the worst
you just go in the closet
it looks like you were on the toilet i'm
not on the toilet this is my
this is my my i don't know what to do i
just want to see your place is super
cute though it is very clean lines nice
work british comedy market is play is
paying incredibly well
multiple rooms yeah and we always have
an extra space
um that we will kick you out of after
three to four weeks
you will be going are you living in
england no no i live in silver lake
okay i was gonna say somebody said
something about how or he spends a lot
of time
in the british comedy community it's
good it pays well
it really did because american comics
like maria bamford
started doing well at places like
melbourne comedy festival and i thought
maybe there was an opportunity there
and wow and they also review
comedy like it's something you put more
than
10 minutes of thought into which i
disagree with i liked it better when we
were
break listed right between karaoke and
strip clubs yeah
yeah don't add nuance to us just leave
it where it's supposed to be
don't bring yeah like that's what made
everything [ __ ]
like we aren't maria has a
review ever poisoned the way you view
your act like you said someone given you
a death
too much of a fluffy
interview or or yeah like like put a
point of view on you
like what she's saying is really about
the seals
oh um well
i think it's just one you just feel bad
like a
like a three-star review where you go oh
i shouldn't even exist
like i want to be at the half star i
want to be one star
where i'm at least providing inspiration
for people
who yeah you can't do anything
or you know you want to be doing very
well but um
yeah so i've gotten a couple of three
stickers ones that have been pretty
sad they've been right i guess i mean a
positive review
where it's something that you just
thought was fun and dumb
and then someone puts this extra meaning
on it where it's like she's actually
talking about inequality and poverty
with women with bangs you're like ah i
didn't
mean any of that well and i think that's
what critique is about is to uh make it
not as funny right so it breaks down
is it the purpose or the absolute side
effect of it the only thing you can get
from reviewing comedy outside of is the
joke funny or not is
is there nuance in the joke and i think
we all share the same thought with our
favorite comedians there usually is not
and so it's a person looking for
something deeper in
a place that doesn't need to be that
deep and even if it is or it isn't it
shouldn't value the comedy
lesser more like i remember i got three
and a half star at um
i'm drawing a blank on the on the
wonderful theater in london
that everybody goes to yeah so theater
i'll stay with you that was a great show
but they gave me a three and a half and
it was like he's up there [ __ ] around
and like having fun it's like what is
that we don't do that here i'm like oh
okay that's
that's fair but then i went on twitter
and it was like this long thread from
this black girl
who's just like i want to go see jack
knight show and i love american humor
and
that like they're both they're both
wrong it was
phenomenal but like right but but it was
the
i definitely sat with the the thread
more than i said with the review
what was your thesis when you said uh
booty be like
well it it all it all started at the at
the ripe age of 16.
and uh i want you to commit to this
little conceit right now and actually
take us from 16 to present day
jack that's what i was it was it was
just drinking and trying to figure out
what can i destroy
in front of me but also like comics like
comics there are good critics and bad
critics some critics i don't respect and
some critics are really unlike
you know film geek dot
co dot nz and some critics aren't like
like really like ao scott or paulie and
kale like there are really good
critics who do really good criticism
melbourne
what some of my favorite reviewers were
from melbourne like when we when i did
all-stars
like the way they broke down everybody i
was like i agree with all of this
we suck
i don't read reviews but i pay my but my
friend
adam reads all the reviews and he's like
hey
every review is mentioning that you do
this so do you want to keep doing
that and that is a really good thing to
have my problem when i do a lot of shows
in a row
like for a month is that whatever the
best
response i got that's that's what i'm
gonna expect every show
from then on and if i don't do it i'll
just like try to
be over something trying to get it out
of them so i always have to
does that make sense yeah has any of you
taking a negative review as like oh
that's actually right
because it's also kind of a giant grain
of salt of like
well you don't do this you know you
write about who you think is good but
you don't actually you're not on stage
but if you take in a negative review and
then like
i do do that thing i do bail early in
2015 kat williams said that i'm built
silly and i need to use it
so i i
like why is he very writing for vulture
why
he pulled me is he was wearing two fur
coats the underneath one was purple the
top one was white
and he was with two women who didn't
want to be there and he watched my whole
set
and then like went joke for joke and
broke it down and what he liked and
didn't like
nothing of like interest and then he
stops he goes looks me up and then he
goes
you're built silly you need to use that
did you change your act in terms of
people i tried to definitely like
be more animated when i deliver a joke
in march when we're all allowed to do
this
but uh i don't know why we're speaking
like we're currently performing every
night but
i don't know i know i know moses is but
i am i'm here
i'm out there at super spreader events
uh performing korea
you had an inter a review that made you
think different
you know these are amalgamation of
several thousand criticisms that i've
had
um most of them on youtube saying i
should kill myself
surprisingly how many times when i've
already thought of it so many times
myself
um but uh no they said uh
that i have um
that's not an insult when i i'm already
thinking of it
um you know all my voices sound the same
very true i only do about six voices
i i totally agree to that and then um
that
i not uh political in terms of
i will say something very passive
aggressively which is ins
so you're not totally clear where i
stand if i yeah i don't actually say
outright um you know donald trump
is a you know like i won't say it i'll
just uh yeah do a metaphorical thing
which is very true once i did a terrible
show
fresno california uh where i did not
rehearse for the show and as i've grown
older i need to rehearse
um anyways didn't rehearse i mumbled
uh throughout the show not the greatest
idea i wrote the stuff you'd think i'd
project it
yeah and uh i refunded everyone their
money
um and then some of those people re uh
gave that refunded ticket money to a
local
mental health charity
unprompted yes where was this
on uh it was in fresno uh there's a big
theater in fresno
on mental health fresno california you
know the progressive thought leaders
of fresno that is insane
but they were not wrong but it was what
was hilarious is after the show it was
like
very you know people were fans saying oh
it's great show great trip
but then there was like this big thing
on facebook just people saying
i really i was really disappointed and
they were correct i was defensive at
first and then i listened to it and i
was like
oh [ __ ] oh i'm sorry
um so so sometimes i think criticism is
extremely helpful
um to go wow i i need to be honest that
i
i need to rehearse before shows
otherwise uh
i might uh be mealy-mouthed and
confused on stage that makes me feel
better because i do the same
thing like in the hotel people like
let's meet up before the show i
i run the entire hour out loud like a
psycho
in my hotel room where i need to talk
because i'm just not good if i don't do
it
i don't do that that's so wild to me
that you but like it makes
to me being prepared as i i record every
show and then i listen back the next
morning but i before i go on stage i try
to have my mind be like
i try to focus on the songs that are
playing from the front of house playlist
so that i don't
so that because for me selling a show
like set like like trying to sell the
material
after i've done it a bunch of times is
its own
unique challenge so i feel like if i
rehearse it i'm gonna be like
hey how's everybody doing tonight
fantastic okay
so i was at the super you know like it's
just gonna come out oh to be excited
about stuff you've been doing for a
while
yeah and i don't perform probably i'm
not performing as much as you do
but you're also a a integral
live performer in that the kind of
laughs you get i mean the three of us
we've all been
in the back of the room when you're
performing it's not the
kind of laugh where it's like i
recognize a joke happens
you're getting like deep guttural laughs
from something that you've committed
so hard to that there's no balance
there's no like
part of people laughing like she's
really doing this for a group of adults
so i i
and not understand here's the written
joke next
you have to warm up your voice your
whole instrument
yeah and and it's also i've gotten older
and and also with the loss of ambition
with age
which i just don't
generally don't care as much so i i have
to
i have to do it over and over again um
to to remind myself
of of what i wrote down um yeah
and i'll do it for other people off
twitter too because i can't i can't even
get myself to do it by myself
in the hotel room i have to get a fan to
meet me
at a donuts parking lot and we'll i'll
do it from there
you tweet that and sometimes want to be
the person i'm not kidding you'll be
like hey
is anybody and i'm like i'll go to
houston today if
i can spend an hour just hearing your
jokes face to face wait you you would
you would do this before covid you would
rehearse for
someone i thought this was just a copy
thing no before covid i
for a couple the last couple years i've
just uh
just because i need to rehearse and i
don't have the willingness to do it by
myself anymore
i have to get a witness and uh and
twitter is beautiful uh you can get
somebody to meet you at any time of day
i just say
uh i don't tell everyone where it is but
just the the one person i pick
and then it's always turned out to be
super nice person
um because they're afraid too does that
person come to the show
later or they're like well i saw it at
dunkin donuts so yeah exactly
sometimes i'm like oh my god why are you
coming to the show tonight
you've already seen it but uh yeah i i
don't
yeah it's the only i haven't had any bad
experiences but
i've also kind of done some like if
somebody has
because you know what somehow you get
fans who don't listen to any of your
politics
and they're like you're just fun we love
you from
target you know yeah you're so funny
we saw just a billboard of you at the
target and we're like
what is her from 15 years ago but then
there's like some
flags and yeah people talking about
skull shapes you're like
yikes i don't want to do well for you
yeah so that's
that's and it's helped me and i yeah
i've been doing the zoom things where i
do it
one-on-one with people um and i'll do it
as a six foot distance
too you know what uh outside if people
want that here in duluth
i've been doing that a little bit for
you and jack of a question so you've
gone
the other way i think right away as a
comedian you went
even i was a little reluctant to do
online and zoom shows which is like this
is so depressing but you went
right in right away to zoom shows jack
i don't know where it's posted but i
have not seen you do any online shows
outside of this one
here i mean no i i only came here
because i
love everybody that's here outside that
i just didn't see a point
i'm sorry i just didn't see a point to
doing it and i felt that this was the
time
to learn something new and build other
parts of what you do as a comedian and
so i've been
doing mostly that during this period
like i missed stand up with like i
genuinely go through phases where i'm
like oh all of this is not worth it
without stand up
and then i like get sad about it i
genuinely like have those little
breakdowns but i've fortunately found
two to three other things that i can do
and and
and have ready for when covet is never
done
what are what are those things for
someone that is because i've talked to
friends that are comedians that are
really having a hard time with this
yeah i know for me it's like i i like
live performing and i
hate this i like talking to people but i
hate you know just performing
like this what what are the things that
you've found that
are fulfilling enough to keep you
motivated doing that thing
even though there's no end in sight
there's no promise that like whatever
you're writing is going to be made or
i just got fortunate that before
everything kind of went down i got lucky
with some
with a network and so we're making a
thing but
it was it was just like diving into
animation as much as i possibly can and
even being a big fan of seeing what
maria has done on
big mouth was like inspirational in
itself and like
understand like when you're such a
stand-up for the beginning part of your
career you kind of
you you know other [ __ ] but you don't
know it and so
i've just been going back and like doing
my research and like so if i'm going to
have these conversations with these
people
i need to not just know gandhi
tarnikovsky i need to know everybody
that led to it giddy karskowski i need
to know everybody that led
to a ralph basket i need to know
everybody that led to aaron magruder on
boondocks like i gotta understand
these animation studios these people and
like the same way that
us four can sit around and talk [ __ ] and
we can name comedians from the 1920s to
now
i want to have that same level of
knowledge when it comes to
and that's just how i feel that's why
i've been on it well you can tell you
lean
heavily into anime because of the sword
behind you
what's it from is there there must be
more to that katana than just katanas
are guns in japan see they don't even
make them there she had to order this
from china
oh my god and it is fully functional
this is a is a covered purchase is there
any plan of like
pure purchase
[Laughter]
when you're like making a salad do you
just like take a katana to the cucumber
you have it in the house
i i i used to be on a daily tip where i
would just like
play jodeci and play with the sword but
now it's like
i like hurt myself and didn't tell
nobody so like i was just like all right
i'm not going to play with it
jack holds up for him
i like i cut the back of my calf and
then like
everybody around me you're gonna end up
cutting yourself you're gonna have
cutting yourself
i cut the back of my calf didn't tell
nobody it was just like no i just you
know it's more decoration i don't really
think i should be like you know
if moses comes back with a weapon of
some kind i'm gonna freak out oh my god
are you kidding me beautiful i accept
this because i'm so embarrassed of this
purchase
you carry a sword with you on the road
you're [ __ ] me not on the road i
bought this at 14 because i was very
into lord of the rings
and uh had hit no puberty so i looked
maybe 10
and i would act out scenes in the
backyard
with this exact sword i've not let it go
because it's
such an embarrassing purchase with a lot
of money
for 14. bought it off ebay had to
had to intercept the package before my
mom found it because we were not allowed
to
buy anything at all and
around moses i've got the same i've got
the same thing these i had
i also this was this was made in taiwan
not china or japan but it does
yeah probably longer than
you've gotten into contracting
you've gotten into scamming rich people
out of construction projects and saying
it's gonna take way longer
than it and it helps marie what was uh
was there any apprehension or you just
leaned right away into the zoom shows
when jack was like okay
let's do something else you were like i
need to perform again
can i mention again that i'm old and
i've tried different things like um
i've tried script writing and stuff like
that and he says
oh i just i'm not good at it and so i
just i'm just doing the things
that i'm good at so now i have uh i have
some internet
you know oh i give people stickers um
that's a
that's a sticker during the show kamala
harris who is that
no guess what they have um
multicultural also um empowering female
stickers
at your local michael's our craft store
um also you can just uh oh what if i put
on a mustache halfway through the show
michael's is for white people that have
a lot of time on their hands
absolutely crafts you know we were like
we support you
here's i may decide oh you have a
mustache look at this
this is what happens when comedians
don't have stand up
some of us have stickers and mustaches
mustaches
unless i'm sore i i'm insanely into my
airfryer
oh really i have a ninja air fryer and i
talk about that every day
i have nothing so all i do is like yo i
bet you i can i can burn your sandwich
can you put oreos in there yeah i put
some flour batter on that [ __ ]
we can frost oreos come on over
that's so [ __ ] cool coolest diabetic
of all time
you sprout that [ __ ] i've made
two uh two batches of fried chicken
since coved
and uh it is very hard to make uh
it is so good and then very difficult to
make
so uh kfc has a log
that you can burn that smells like fried
chicken
they put out and sell they sell it at
walmart and
um i don't know who would do that to the
family oh look at this air fryer that's
what you need
right in there that's what you need
maria oh my god
let me know let me know you want me to
pull up with my air fryer we can get the
chicken really going with you moses that
seems so
so cruel a lot so you can you imagine if
that started a forest fire and so for
like 90 000 acres
of southern california
i hope so is that smell burned in your
memory because uh
alex used to work at a kfc in of all
places
penn station yes i um
here's the thing people are like do you
hate fried chicken i'm like no i just
hate fried chicken that comes
out of a bag frozen so every other kind
of
fried chicken if i see it made and it's
not coming directly out of a bag frozen
i love it but i haven't been to you know
i didn't go to kfc for years after i
stopped working
um in the in the fine dining game
uh because you don't you know you don't
return to vietnam
but it was yeah you didn't go back on
vacation but it was
uh it was really yeah you start to smell
like those places too
it's a really i have a great like sense
memory and i
dated someone in high school she worked
at kfc and it was just
it was a constant she'd shower and it
was just always in her pores
and also you smell not just like you
don't smell like fried chicken you smell
like a combination of all the
ingredients and i was a kosher juice so
i couldn't eat bacon and my friends were
like i'm sorry but you smell like
a little bit like bacon and a bunch of
other stuff
so like why do you like smell forbidden
what is going on here
did you ever as a as a orthodox jew have
to assemble a baconator
[Laughter]
it was one of those hazmat suits i had
to put it on
so i actually had bacon once on accident
my um my roommate in college had some
macaroni and cheese in the fridge
and i asked if i could have some and as
i was eating it i was like
these sun-dried tomatoes are incredible
and he's like what sun-dried
oh no and like i was real theatrical
about it i really milked it i like went
to the
the garbage and like spat it out and
everyone was like you're still going
ahead
you know like it's not uh do you feel
guilty about it or do you just
i feel like you're a best thing that's
ever happened to me but uh
he's eating bacon all the time he has do
you have to
you have to go talk to somebody after
you do that like how do you renew your
license after you
plunder so in catholicism you have a
priest but in judaism you have to write
a letter to mel brooks
no no you're fine you're fine you just
you just keep you just keep going you do
whatever
alex did you ever have the pace no and
yes because so the reason the pace of
those curly ear locks
there's a biblical commandment that you
have to keep some of
some of this around your ears so this is
why i do that
like i have these nice because the idea
to keep you celibate
what like the worst haircut to keep you
celibate yeah
yes they give you plenty of protection
when you're young when you're a young
man
no i but i put on to fill in every day
those those leather things that you put
on your
on your arm and when i do that there are
these
they do a prayer over you i did this on
uh birthright
i think if your name is moses you can
lie and say you're jewish and now you
went out of birth right
well my dad is technically jewish and
but you're only jewish if your mom is
jewish
but it was enough and they saw moses and
the whole idea behind birthright is just
wait
you're you're half jewish moses
yeah are you kidding me all of us are
everyone is you're such a perfect like
you look like someone who would have
been chasing me 70 years ago i'm
i you're jewish i call moses moshe
as like a joke and the joke is because
to me but that's
that makes i mean not culturally but
like free trip
absolutely where a program is trying to
get just
the whole idea behind birthright is that
you will hook up with someone on your
trip
move there and there'll be more of you
than there is palestinians
it's like rachel dolezal went to the bed
awards
didn't she really isn't that true
but that would be amazing he's hosting
the mass singer which is not
it's rachel dolezal
it's so funny because when you're in
your early 20s you want to win
every award you want to do everything i
remember watching like
the the image awards and i was like how
do i win one of those like how is that
gonna how am i gonna get something some
reward from
i might get a soul train award or
something like that the amount of
outrage that you would get
alex edelman my dad working on christmas
yes i would be this is true i would be
the first white person to
ever um appropriate uh black music for
their own benefit that would be i'd be
the first one
absolutely wow crazy i just love the
idea dc young flap being like
alex what just come on
yeah i want to thank the amigos uh i
want to thank
rick rubin i want to thank aaron
magruder actually one of my favorite one
of my
boondocks is so good jacket since you
said that there's so much good animation
it's really stunning
yeah are you working on your own project
now what uh
can you talk about it yeah but trying is
there a deadline
no i hope never i don't want to ever be
i don't want anyone to quote tweak my
accomplishments
that's my biggest we're always attached
i'm gonna say
that's my biggest fear it's like
something to be announced and then above
it it's just like
in 2016 he called me fat and it's like
well just don't announce it just put the
show out don't even say i'm not even
anywhere near yeah
well i wonder how much the animation has
has
influenced you as a performer what i've
noticed is i if you guys this
is like a very real plug and not like a
show busy thing you got you and um zac
fox have a
doomsday mixtape so good which is the
podcast but it just it divulges into
some of the best riffs that are it could
be sketches
it could be a key and peel type show
in that i'm howling laughing i'm like
falling asleep
let's do a podcast and it's upsetting
so i wonder how much animation has
changed that in your mind when you start
thinking of things as not
because i think before you're doing like
concept jokes where you're like
here's this idea i know it's unpopular
let me argue for
the lawyer thing and i think now at
least what you guys are doing on that
podcast
seems like you're you're essentially
talking out sketches especially with you
and alex
uh you guys have like these 13-minute
ideas that you just perfectly break down
and it's funny every beat of the way
and that just wasn't the way that i was
raised to be funny
you know i mean like it was just like i
was i was raised in such
short bursts who's the loudest who can
say the
most abrasive sentence at the back of
this bus
who can get the most amount of attention
in his lunchroom as fast as possible
and so you can't really break down a
whole story about how you broke your leg
on a ferris wheel in
middle school and that's why you
couldn't go on a date with something
like i did that was
and that's my greatest adversity story i
was just like that i feel like
that feels like it's aimed at roasting
either one of us and i'm like
touche good sir wait great example but
it's like i would watch it like these
guys are [ __ ]
brilliant it was my arm and a
tilt-a-whirl
[Laughter]
it was just and moses is right moses has
known me since i started comedy and like
he's there like it's just been more evil
like i've evolved from
the same way i've been telling jokes
since me and him were like in our early
20s
jack and i started open mics he would
essentially say the most outrageous
thing and then build a case around why
that was true until people were on his
side
yeah a level of confidence you know why
we're at these terrible open mics was
just
something i learned from and it was like
oh i didn't know you could do that
on the other side with uh maria i used
to intern at ucb
and i would just watch your stuff over
and over again
i didn't know you could leave the
audience in that i feel like you go so
deep into character that a lot of the
time you're like checking with the
audience can i continue here's this joke
do you like it it feels like you're so
laser focused on these characters that
you just leave and you do the character
it was that
always something that you had or did you
learn that from somewhere because i
that is something that i've directly
stolen from you okay
no i uh i think i just i'm not i'm an
introvert
so i'm not i'm not super comfortable
it's not my go-to to be
with people uh usually so
you're not like look at this guy's shirt
look at you flannel again
which i love as an audience member like
i love oh my god
you saw my sweater and my necklace
like i love that but i i'm
so awkward and sort of a cold fish type
person like i've tried to be
um more gregarious on stage and it's
just everyone's like
oh you know so um
yeah i tried to just be like here's the
story of you know
maple leaves just didn't feel right
well and i think it's the way i grew up
my dad would give me three minutes to
talk
at the dinner table or i think it was
five minutes he would set a timer
um
that's so crazy because i was quiet and
my sister and my mom
just talked to like their their big
interrupters and they can just talk and
talk and
talk it forever and um i just
i will be silent and i've actually done
it before i was once on a show in
australia whereas on the show
was a chat show for a full hour it was
supposed to be where you're supposed to
jump in and
like is it the great debate
i uh uh yes i said nothing for 60
minutes
i've seen that change you are not lying
you're not lying wait
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry can we go
back
to the
this is your chance to talk as if you
didn't get to speak and this is your
chance to get it or is it
you need to talk bro we need you to
actually converse with his family
um no it was this is your chance like
this is your chance
everyone's got to be quiet um because
otherwise i won't
i won't get to get to talk because i
would try to say something
but i would just feel kind of like and i
still feel the same way with my family
like my sister's
hilarious and she's just louder than me
and so um yeah that's part of the
longing to be
amplified and lit in front of thousands
is uh
due to her so the timer goes off and
it's a hard like
before your punch line of your story
it's just no more
it's a hard out which is what i'm
calling my disappearance at the age of
75.
[Laughter]
do you ever feel guilty that you're
selling something out like i feel guilty
sometimes about like exploiting a
poverty narrative and growing up
homeless sometimes do you ever feel like
you're leaning too much in that for
industry sakes of like
generals like we were talking about
reviews like i know you went to a
white nationalist meeting yeah how much
of that was for the show and how much
was that
for your genuine curiosity as a human
being it's for everything i do is for my
gen
the genuine curiosity of of my life
or like my investing in my sincere side
means going to like white nationalist
meetings
and i've gone to churches and mosques
and places that jews shouldn't
or places that jews usually aren't and
i've gone to
different countries when i was in south
korea for the olympic my brother
my brother was in south korea competing
in the olympics which is a whole other
thing
wait he doesn't want you to talk about
him hey i just wanted to keep a low
profile
well he doesn't want to be mocked but i
i don't feel guilty talking about what
it
means to be jewish i would feel guilty
if i talked about
jews but it's certainly not for like
industry's sake because like you say
it's not super unique
to be a jew but like that is a big part
of my identity so when i talk about that
and i have things that
sometimes people go oh man your shows
are so like personal but like
i have different things that i think are
personal like i don't talk about my
romantic relationships or my
interpersonal relationships on stage
because that to me is like
my private life i always feel guilty now
you know that i do stuff about my
family and it's like well yeah i'm
trying to just talk about myself now
because i
yeah realize how that can be hurtful to
people
um but i started talking about i'm in a
jillion 12-step groups or
three three three and um
you know one of the things that i i
sincerely respect about those things
are that they they are safe spaces
you know to but then they are so
funny that i feel like i
have to tell jokes about them because
it it like i i have to i have to say
one of the rules of 12-step cults is
that you're not supposed to say that
you're in a specific group
um like you're not supposed to say i'm
um you just say cults maria
yes that's a fair description though
that's why i've been turned off by
anything
that's like that of like i mean
they're cults because they have these
weird rules where you go i mean
the one thing that i like that makes it
less occult in 12 step
is that it's free number two free number
three
they can't kick you out like even if i
go to all the meetings and
you know bring a bottle of jack daniels
and i'm eating an ice cream cake
with a stolen porn dvd all anyone will
say is you newcomer keep coming back
but you're scooping the ice cream cake
with the porn deviant
with the prawn dvd oh my god it's not
coming back
you come back the next week with
slightly lower proof alcohol and they're
like okay
you're just you're getting there no no
it's great to have you here have you
ever tried to push it though
like what what what could i do um oh
yeah i mean i do talk i've started
talking about in my zoom shows like
about which ones i'm in uh which feels
like it feels like i shouldn't um
because it is this one private thing
in my life that i've felt um
yeah like somehow i shouldn't break the
rule or it's disrespectful or something
yeah and sincerity and all that stuff so
anyways it's um it's odd to be able to
have something that is private and
important to you but
also how can you share the
ridiculousness of it as
as well so that's what i'm having
trouble with right now is
family members even though it's my
experience that this happened
have asked me to not do certain things
or they've tried to correct the record
even though
this is my experience or i'm bending it
because it's funny
how do you handle that responsibility as
far as like i'm about to put out
especially never
we'll see when that happens but i i
generally wonder because it's like stuff
that means something to me i feel better
that i can process this pain and make
people laugh
uh but the people that i'm talking about
are like
you know i see it different actually
happened this way i've told like my
sister's written three books
i said awesome you you tell your site
about childhood or about our religion
about childhood about
memoirs about um stuff and and
and i didn't you know edit her
experience
about um yeah like she had a whole
one hilarious point of view where she
she said the reason she beat me up so
much as a kid
was because she was she knew i was too
sensitive and she was trying to make me
tougher
so i'd be ready for the real world and
i'm like
really yeah i guess it was like
the hard part is she beat you up to a
timer
exactly i think you were just 12
and you were uh having a terrible time
and you just thought
i think i'll punch this kid in the gut
at least she ever to reason
none of my bullies ever submitted in
writing why they were bullying me
exactly so as a performer how much
responsibility do you have to be like
well no i know it's entertaining for the
crowd and it's
it's my experience which is this versus
protecting someone that didn't sign up
to be in the entertainment industry or
to have their
dirty laundry aired out the first time i
was ever on tv i talked about how
fire my mom's [ __ ] must have been
so i i've only spoken pretty positively
about
the people like the first joke i've ever
made it's that two five story
yeah that one too it was just like my
mom's [ __ ] is so fast the only reason
why i'm dope and
you can tell who's people who you can
tell who has
terrible mom [ __ ] by their behavior
like if you meet someone and
tag tag punch punch if they act like
this you know their mama [ __ ] is dry
and then you know i was 21 at the time
and then tommy smith was like yeah we
can just put that on tv
yeah and my mother is a principal of a
high school at the time
and they all saw the joke and she is now
a legend
that's hilarious nice you're principal
nice just a bunch of 15 16 year old boys
trying to mess with some [ __ ] that's
above they pay great
[Music]
my mom had a great attitude towards that
you know
stuff too like she um i think
she she did just pass away and my dad
was
decluttering a few after that hours
after she died
wow and um that's a bad way to process
things as far as like yeah i could use
it
we got to clean up we just need to like
put things somewhere well we're not
going to need any of this anymore
let's make a trip to goodwill um he uh
got uh he handed my sister and i uh a
shoe box
and he said very solemnly um
in it were a large uh
high quality uh purple plastic dildo
vibrator
and then a a small butterfly style
vibrator and he said she would have
wanted you
girls to have these oh my
goodness and it's true
it's true she would i i said yeah i'll
take them
but my sister said no you will not and
she saged them
and then threw them in the trash she
saved them to pass on to her children
these were yours that would have been so
sweet it's like a family watch
did you want to hang on to it for the
sentimental value or just like
for me and my head are like growing poor
and like the money like those are those
things
those are pricey that's what i thought i
thought
that's like 200 bucks down the rain was
shipping vintage vibrators
well they were brand new i mean these
were some good looking models
i like that it's passed down like a
sword yeah i really hope there's like
someone that works at bloomhouse
listening because i think that
i got haunted by my mom's vibrator the
come on bro this is like right there
just easy money oh my god it's so true
it's the ghost of everyone she thought
of while she was using it
her boyfriend from high school roger
gets he was jewish
and it was probably the reason my mom
was an honorary member of hadassah
i'll check at the meeting on tuesday
maria i'll see if anyone knows
that's so funny you know i was in duluth
for the first time
last year and i walked i walked up to
the bob dylan
house because there's a house that dylan
was born in he's got a childhood home
and um and i'm outside the house and
this woman comes out on the porch and
she's like
bob dylan and i'm like yeah she's like
you want to see the house and i'm like
sure so she takes me and uh takes me
into bob dylan's
house and uh there's a husband sitting
in a kitchen table reading a magazine
and he sees me it's like bob dylan and
i'm like yeah he's like yeah
go upstairs and like it's just a real
insane
thing that it's wonderful it was so cool
and then the woman was like you know
about the armory show right and i was
like
no idea and i guess the last show buddy
holly played before he died
bob was at this armory in duluth bob
dylan went as a teenager and was in the
front row
and there's a photo that i saw while i
was in duluth of bob dylan in the front
row looking
at buddy holly which is like so
so creepy and and crazy and weird that
is great well and
i look the one thing i love one of many
things i love about duluth
is that it is ridiculously easy to
get in touch with anybody like my
husband likes this um
band called low and they're from duluth
um and uh we just facebook
you know messaged them and they said
want to get lunch today like it's not
like
you know elliott in new york it's like
uh can we
reschedule it in 2022 um
right i got a window was it like what is
it like alex
it's like alan sparhawk in them ellen
spurhawk
his wife mimi we've been to their house
now
that's wild that's insane so it's just
like now it's not like l.a like we
should do we should we have to hang out
and then you'll see them in two years
this is like
no they're like no we're you're coming
over
right yeah no it's really uh yeah uh a
huge fan of you guys
do you want to live together okay
exactly
that's what you did that's exactly what
she did to me the most is i was like
we've got extra space i've always wanted
to have kids in theory
so i figure if somebody's in their 30s
it's like uh
i can handle it for three to four weeks
i'll make you eggs
comics are so charitable sometimes it's
like insane like
the amount of comedians who like who
have hosted me in like various countries
and cities
like elaine boozler i did like one show
with elaine boozler and she's like
stay at my place when i'm like and it's
a real
like it's a real community that's what i
miss so much about this like i ran into
i ran into chris fleming on the street a
couple of weeks ago and i wanted to like
grab his leg and never let go
like i just miss running into people i
miss the whole
yeah but not scheduling people but like
like accidentally seeing people is is
a great way to do it what would it take
for anyone to
perform again like what kind of
restrictions what kind of death rate is
anyone thinking about that or they're
just
moving on a new president the the
that there's some sort of cure that that
would be good because i just wouldn't
want to
do a club and then somebody get ill
yeah my watch right that's my that's my
biggest fear is like i just get an email
it's just like
great show my grandma died yeah yes
what a what a unload to put on you yeah
but and it's your big story about your
mom is [ __ ] worth it i gotta say
it's not that good i'm over there in
maria where it's just like i don't know
man i feel like there's been times in
history where we had to take a break
yeah and this might just be like yeah
everybody take a break everybody
i mean i understand you know he was
promised something that god took from
him
but uh that's how i frame it in my head
and by god i mean deadline
[Laughter]
yeah but you're fine jack to be like i'm
just gonna focus on other things
and be a human being i'm not fine with
it i'm i'm
i would way rather see you guys all the
time i do stand up and be
drunk till 3am at the store or whatever
but you know it is what it is and if you
don't react and
you know change some [ __ ] you gonna just
be a sad sack of the crib
performing in that weird liminal four or
five day
grey space between when the world was
normal when the world was shut down it's
crazy
i feel comfortable saying this but i
said to my i was on tour i was like
legit on a tour of the uk that had a
couple weeks left and
and i said to my agent like hey i think
i should cancel the shows
because kat cohen had cancelled her
shows and gone home and i called her and
i was like is there going to be a
problem and she wrote bro
yeah and so my agents were like
why what's the big deal like it's not a
problem and i was like yeah and then my
dad is
my dad is in charge of distributing ppe
now for the hospitals and universities
in massachusetts and he called me he's
like
hey uh you know i never tell you what to
do but maybe you should look into
cancelling your shows
and so i called the agents back and i
was like i want to cancel the shows and
they're like
you are so alarmist but like we will
deal with this sort of like
jewish neuroses and this is my uk
these are my uk agents and they're like
we
we shut it down but i did one last show
in glasgow
and and that night had like a real like
last dance on the titanic feel to it it
was like a real
i was like welcome to the last show
we're gonna go to for five months
and people really it had a special
sad feeling to it that i'll never be
able to forget
and those agents by the way like their
whole company shut down like that that
could then
they don't one of them's like working as
a carpenter now
my goodness that's such a far fall that
seems like a ridiculous far from grace
like everybody everybody at quibby
already has a new job
how bad do you be like hope it's not
real because then you have to do
construction
yeah bro they call that the reverse
jesus where you go from an elevated
position back to carpentry
and see so now he doesn't send you
scripts he just sends you tape measures
he generally was like hey i'm working on
this table
and like that's the kind of thing he's
like working on this table do you want
to be involved we got a good perfect no
but like
i got leg attached legs are attached uh
we're circling some stain we're looking
at
mahogany but moses does spend lots of
time on deadline that his
that uh that's the just keep refreshing
keeps refreshing every moment we've got
something
who's doing what is anyone doing better
than me must be held at work at deadline
if you have any showbiz aspirations that
every day you just get a hundred notices
of people who are like
who have something fun to announce
deadline is just the school
announcements of the entertainment
business
well it's just a dude comes in just like
uh
in the morning we'll have a new show
with jason bateman and newcomer
right but the the one is when someone
gets recast
at the table read when they that makes
you feel better about your entire life
and the fact that you hit someone with
your car in 2013. it's like well they
showed up
they were who they are and they weren't
good enough oh my god
i don't think i can up that you know
your story is more beautiful but my last
performance was
at the the new stand in that lower room
yeah
awesome super [ __ ] awesome room love
those people over there love you guys
and i was on a scout with my buddy
richie keane
for a show that me and my friends were
getting ready to make
and because of covert it all just shut
down you know life is fine
move on but it was like we're making the
tv show we were scouting moses knows all
this
we're making a tv show we're scouting we
were look we were like getting all the
shots down we
fully went through our list we got
everybody ready to go the monday
whenever like the whole way when tom
tom hanks got it the day we shut
everything down and
uh trump said he's gonna shut down all
flights and so
uh viacom had to give me an earlier
flight had to put me on a flight back to
la so i wouldn't be trapped in new york
i get to
i get there and everybody from the uk
is just standing in a group because they
wouldn't let them fly home
yeah and so it was just really like
scary like
everybody was being incredibly rude to
asian people like i was watching the
xenophobia happen in front of my eyes
like it was
it was crazy and then there was just
like a group of some biscuit eating
[ __ ] just standing off to the
side
with nowhere to go your fire has changed
i luckily got on the plane flew over we
were like ah
you know this is just like people going
crazy nope
literally the last show i did was at the
stand
hanging out with like i think it was
like who was there that night
like clayton english was with me for
some reason it was it was just a great
night
and then the whole world shut down even
live stand up now in moses i'm sure your
experience is different and i'm
i'm about to like i'm gonna do some
clubs at the end of the year but like
i did a show where the stage was the
back of a pickup truck
and i looked out and i was just like
what kind of world are we living in
we're just like live from the thunder
dome
you're just like is every show has like
a genuine
post-apocalyptic feel to it i'm with
jack a bit on zoom shows like
i i do them now because i can't live
without
some kind of stand-up but it feels very
much like
i bombed a couple weeks ago two feet
from my bed
like that's hard can't leave the venue
yeah like if i really want to look at a
place i truly bond i have to go to like
sunnyvale california and remember 2013
now it's just like oh yeah i remember
three months ago where on my couch i
bombed like where a guy kept playing
video games with his sister while i was
on stage
oh that's great they completely tuned
out yeah
just completely that's that's better
than not levy it's just like i
it's on your a tab that's the other
thing there's no like audience
accountability people flag when if
they heckle it's like that [ __ ]
wisconsin what you're really going to do
yeah you're gonna come back it'll just
turn off his camera you can't crush a
heckler who lives
in a like a different state so everyone
uh
can stay on except maria you have three
seconds to
say who you are i'm so sorry
uh yeah we are out of time but this is
honestly so much fun
that um you know i was out in a very
real way having a rough morning for
whatever reason
and uh this made me feel better so thank
you for for uh
coming on this with me it's just nice to
see everybody now it's good to see
people's faces does anyone have anything
uh coming up that they want to uh get
the message out
about i know jack has uh doomsday
mixtape which is the podcast i was
talking about which
i highly highly recommend don't fall
asleep to it it's
hilarious so good i think big mom's
coming out at some point some other news
will probably come out when
white people allow me to say it i'm
giving you permission
[Laughter]
um i've got an album out i just put out
an album because i was like i need
somehow to
still be putting out stand-up but i put
out an album called until now which i
recorded
acme maria in minneapolis i love acne
i love it and also
um i've been phone banking for the
abiding campaign a lot and if people
have spare time now you should phone
bank it's super easy
and apparently it really helps so like
now it sounds so dumb
but like i don't know be really nice to
have a
new president in a couple of weeks so so
maybe just don't ruin my birthday
is that your birthday check my birth my
birthday is the sixth so whatever
happens on the third
i know the voting is probably gonna take
one to two weeks to actually get
everything together and i know they're
gonna try and destroy the election we
can talk about this another day
but just like let me at least if you're
gonna if you're
either blow by now the water and we're
like we live in a terrible place
don't make it some weird contention that
my birthday is awkward
yeah right everyone needs to phone bank
we're
not doing any birthday yeah either biden
blows him out or trump blows him out but
i need my day
you need your day it's important too
that's very scorpio that's very scorpio
you have anything coming up that people
should check out i have a free
audible book that you can get on uh
audible um
called you are a comedy special um it's
about two hours long and it's a
15 step guide how to write your own uh
one hour comedy for how to force
yourself
force yourself first yourself right a
full hour of comedy
uh because uh that's what i have to do
um it doesn't come naturally anyway so
that's the only thing i have to plug
great so you're selling two vibrators
in case anybody well i have to say
bills have been saged and put in a local
trash for duluth minnesota
illegal to sell things that have been
saged um that's our show this is
this is uh so fun i know i'm very proud
thank you moses
yeah thank you guys
thank you so nice to see you maria
bamford alex edelman and jack knight
uh thank you and and hang in there hope
you have a great week bye
so that's going to do it for us i'm
moses storm huge thank you to alex
edelman jack knight and maria bamford
for being here
uh in november 17th i want to bring you
something up we're going to do something
a little bit different with moses and
friends
we're going to partner with in crowd and
what they do is essentially a virtual
stand-up show where we're actually on
stage with a mic people doing material
and we are surrounded by screens which
is all of you
so you can buy a ticket to that show and
you can be
a part of the show a lot of times
interaction with the audience or at
least
behind us so you know wear your one good
shirt
that's going to be on november 17th and
we'll
put up a ticket link for that and you
can follow all the info and all the
updates
on the team coco live instagram so team
gogol live on instagram
go there and we hope to see you there
it's gonna be a really fun experience
good night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just need to lose
other's
is
[Music]
[Music]
this time
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was
and stay
[Music]
keep on shining
out of control
just
[Music]
you